she thinks I'm doing a puppy video right
now I have been considering getting in
tattoo for a few years now has crossed
my mind my parents don't know that they
both like never had any tattoos I have
occasionally brought it up to my mom and
she freaks out I'm actually kind of
worried that she's gonna look at this
shirt and be like me too twins I'm like
no dad it's fake
you might deny that it's real or she kid
burst into tears third option I guess
that she could have a heart attack the
tattoo I'm gonna be getting is a flower
really girly and cute I think it's
believable I really hope that you have
an ambulance outside on standby how was
Dodger growing up what kind of echidna
she thought she was a smart girl very
practical didn't get into a lot of
trouble I think Jennifer was born miss
independent from the very beginning
putting her in a stroller and she
wouldn't stay in the stroller a
relationship has matured and I think I
can tell you more things now which is
good I think we're fairly honest with
each other I mean I I don't think we
share every little secret yeah I think I
should tell you oh I don't know your act
I got a tattoo you're full of it
thanks to where to show me am I allowed
like lift up my shirt on here are you
sure
are you joking is it real - oh my god
where did you get that it's not real Jen
yeah
is that permanent where'd you go Santa
Monica there yeah
you know you can't but itis get strands
it's a flower it's cute right I don't
know it looks like a wound you look like
you're gonna cry you look like you're
crying well you're making me feel shitty
now about it well it doesn't make me
happy it's not on you am I just like
felt inclined I was really key
and you have a little bit to drink you
didn't think about asking me you're
calling me you're telling me no I was
kind of worried that you'd be upset well
I don't know I just don't like in that
location I think it doesn't look good
everyone else in the family knew about
it everybody else knows your dad no dad
no it's Jonathan oh great
did you ask anybody else about it or you
just did it yeah like some friends to
see what they thought they said was cute
they might not let you in the convent
anymore now yeah I know I don't know I'm
gonna do I'm gonna keep that for sure
if Jennifer had asked me first if she
couldn't have a tattoo I mean she she's
older out of my control I mean I'm not
thrilled that I'm I'm not there's too
many other things that are that could be
far worse so Oh
I've one more thing is there another but
I hope in the future that if you want to
do something drastic like that that you
let me know okay
I'll make sure okay how better with that
I have one more secret actually okay
what it's actually a fake tattoo it's
fake and you didn't tell your dad no I
did not talk dad Jonathan oh you're such
a great lawyer did you really hate it
that much when I get past the fact that
you're my daughter and he did get tattoo
now haha but then I want to like
critique that artists I should run it by
you
I appreciate it when Jennifer calls me
and wants me to be with her for whatever
so maybe I'll go get a tattoo after this
you want to come really if I can get a
matching one
[Music]